the wife of one of three British plane
spotters who've been arrested in the
United Arab Emirates says that she would
never have thought his hobby would
result in detention Konrad clithero and
two friends were apparently taking notes
near for Jarett Airport when they were
accused of committing a national
security offence he was really upset
really choked up and kept asking if we
were okay but I was obviously more
concerned if he was okay he didn't have
any information about the case he didn't
really have any information about what
the charges were it was all very unclear
he has had this hobby since he was a
young boy he used to go planes busing
with his father and he's sort of carried
on that tradition you just really enjoy
it and he would never put himself or any
of his friends and family in this sort
of position where we would be so worried
and everybody be under such stress I
don't think for one minute he would have
thought that plane spotting would have
you know caused this sort of issue I'm
joined by Alex birch Eris's of plane
spotting himself and an aviation expert
evening Alex um every now and then cases
like this come up Greece a few years ago
with a whole crowd of Brits got put in
custody and now here in the Emirates I
assume that there's always a bit of a
risk of breaching security involved is
there in some parts there is yes like in
some parts of the world where plane
spotting isn't widely understood for
example in the United Arab Emirates
because it's not understood it's
actually frowned upon and so because of
that lack of understanding they
immediately treat it as suspicious and
and then start raising questions and as
we know at fujairah they have actually
taken action and and put these men in
prison presumably most of you plane
spotters will kind of know the dodgy
places where you might get into trouble
would you you would yes I mean there are
a variety of plane spotters that work
with airports around Europe and in
America and they sort of visit
designated areas where you are allowed
to successfully plane spot you're
allowed to take photos or Latin log
registrations and that's what they sort
of enjoy
however Fedora is a highly sensitive
Airport 80 miles away from Dubai and
there there is a sort of things going on
there they would prefer to be kept
private so I think just by being around
that perimeter fence is risky in the
first place this could be why they've
taken such a drastic measure now is it
made pretty clear to plane spotters
where where which airfields are our
outer bounds because presumably there
are a lot of security issues around the
world on them yes definitely especially
where we've got like air full spaces
where they do you know sort of exercises
that they would rather the public not
know about and so there are signs
warning people you know to stay away
from the fence no photography allowed
and generally they a variety of plane
spotters will you know abide by this but
there are holidays that plane spotters
and you can go online and now it
specifically visits sort of derelict
untouched areas where things are
happening but the plane spotters are
there to sort of grab it on photo on
camera and that's causing problems
across the world well I imagine there
you're you know a naturally nosy bunch
on you you're pretty curious which is
why you you go and take the numbers down
and check all these things out so you
are gonna push the limits on you I think
those in the industry sort of associate
themselves in terms of they they find a
registration for a plane and they'll say
I flew that plane to LA I was a
passenger on that aircraft and then for
some reason that exact registration has
a place in their heart where then they
feel you know it doesn't matter if it
says no photography I was on that plane
last year I'm taking a photo of it now I
mean here in the UK you're turning me
that that actually you there's now a
more sort of formally arranged room with
the airports and with police where
you've pretty much got a pass they know
you're there they know who you are and
they'll allow you in close yes so an
example of this is at Stansted Airport
and they've worked with Essex Police to
ensure that if you want to plane spot
around the airport and the terminal then
you sort of go through them you give
them your details they check you out and
providing everything comes back okay
you get a pass which means that you
won't be hassled and that you can claim
spot in the legal areas safely and
securely and you can help with security
I gather and they do they have a
designated number which they can text or
call to say you know look I've seen
so-and-so over there he hasn't got a
pass he's not an official plane spotter
for that Airport and so maybe he's worth
checking out easy too terribly British
thing plane spotting I mean I can't
imagine many places in the world that
plane spotters about from a star they I
think you'd be surprised I think in
Europe they have much more at America
LA's labelled as the plane spotting
heaven because they build and invest on
terraces at airports purely for people
to visit the airport stand on the
terrace and get the family photo with
the American Airlines jet in the
background well so you'll start right
here travel guide to plane spotting
airports thank you very much charlie the
chair is very good of you to tell us
about your hobby